what's going on reject nation Greg Alba
here so I got one hour asleep I'm in a
YouTube space all day helping film with
my brother but for Lord and Francesca
from I want my lure in a pilot
presentation it will be up on YouTube
keep a lookout for a might not be out
for a while this trailer dropped that
just by hearing the cast got me
intrigued and I was like I gotta check
this out from Warner Brothers movie
called game night sorry and Rachel
McAdams and Jason Bateman I love Rachel
McAdams love Rachel McAdams patron of
the day shoutout today gonna be for
Andrew Hayes
[Music]
[Music]
what jeffrey wright kind of feels like
Horrible Bosses it's every type of like
a mystery movie good what a funny fly
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
so damn adorable okay it's a weird
ending that looks like a much more fun
version of Murder on the Orient Express
right there I like the plot of this game
kind of reminds me of that movie the man
who knew too little but also ever
watching any part of your brain is
thinking maybe this is all just the game
maybe that's the twist at the end of the
movie it's all just a game after all
because I like the setup of them
thinking it's a Gable this horrible
thing is going down and right in front
of them it ends up actually being real
that sounds really funny how can it all
just be a game if a guy clearly gets
killed by that plane rachel mcadams
weird reaction there I don't know here's
what I know Jason Bateman always a
delight to watch Phil you don't really
see Kyle Chandler in comedies and Rachel
McAdams I loved seeing her new comedies
man I think she's great with comedy
she's just so damn adorable yeah she's
so beautiful like even if her
performance is not always great I think
she's a fantastic actress but sometimes
your performance is a little off but
even when they are a little off in like
I don't care you're just so beautiful
and even seeing Jeffrey Wright in a dark
comedy like this I think it would be
weird to see Jeffrey Wright in a comedy
but to see him in a dark comedy makes a
lot more sense especially dealing with
murder and mystery and considering he's
one of the stars of Westworld fantastic
casting choice who directed this movie I
love dark comedies I do love dark
comedies a lot I think tragedy girls is
one of my favorite movies of the year
that was a heavy dark comedy this is the
people who did Horrible Bosses one of
them yeah John Francis daley and
Jonathan Goldstein - Rico directed this
with him he directed they cave
[ __ ] ah which he also did with John
Francis dude
I don't know this has a really
intriguing plot I feel like it's really
gonna commit to the dark comedy even
though some bits seem a little bit off
in terms of you know editing it for a
trailer and I get kind of sick of that
joke of you know it's someone this isn't
a real gun they shoot it it ends up
being real but I thought that was a nice
extra edition where the gun goes off and
then shoots Jason Bateman and then they
have to deal with the talk the the dog
full of blood I thought that was a nice
enhancement to a joke we've seen done a
billion times in a movie this looks
funny and I really like both Horrible
Bosses 1 & 2 and Jason Bateman I think
is fantastic in that in those movies
cast looks great the Edit does look like
a genuine type of plot solving movie how
it actually care to see I'm in and
before this video is done Andrew Hayes
my buddy from New Jersey Andrew Hayes
has his own movie review channel just
type in Andrew Hayes on YouTube this guy
is fantastic at movie reviews he doesn't
have like the greatest set up just yet
I'm giving you guys a heads up on that
however if you just ignore all that I
feel like I'm watching what made YouTube
so great in the beginning when you would
just watch someone talk in front of a
webcam or something like that something
cheap and rod and for a guy who does
videos where he doesn't edit it or read
from something I think he's fantastic at
really speaking so I highly recommend
you guys check out this guy's videos
because he is really good at movie
reviews and I want more people to check
their scribe out anyway guys you can
subscribe to the reel rejects click that
notification bell this video is probably
going up in the morning because I got to
go catch daddy's home too I'm not gonna
watch Murder on the Orient Express I'm
not gonna watch three billboards highly
rated a movie I want to see daddy's home
2 starring Mel Gibson that's me I'm Greg
Alba